you carsick lot I'll tell you what it is
you can't read in the car that's what it
is
or is it that I'm being kidnapped my
name is Amy Belafonte I was 10 years old
with my mom I died hello in him we want
you to see a specialist in Colorado
how come there's no social worker not
gonna didn't signal ad they always send
a lady I would have been all alone if it
wasn't for Brad we'll guest she's 10
years old explain to me why you need a
kid you know the people we work for Brad
you can't cross them
he wished everything to protect me new
plan
we're not going to call right on it's a
bad place problem is there's gonna be
some bad guys looking for us so we got
to find someplace safe which means
you're gonna have to trust me and I know
you may not have good reasons okay okay
I trust you
we became family
I don't use your friend doesn't matter
[Music]
these people are never gonna stop you
know that
who's the girl we've heard them change
everything you might be the most
important of a girl in the world
and I was afraid I wish I knew then what
I know now thought they should be afraid
of me the passage coming this January to
Fox
you